welcome to the five President Biden is
up north in Canada and trying to impress
his pal Justin Trudeau on what Biden
sees as a big foreign visit but his real
problems are piling up back here at home
Joe Biden is tired of putting up with
kamala's endless embarrassments
Democratic sources revealing how Joe is
irked by his vice president not quote
rising to the occasion a former White
House official says that quote a fear of
messing up has led Harris to be late to
the game on important issues adding that
a point of tension in their relationship
is that the president sees her as
somebody who takes as somebody who takes
anything off of his plate Joe Biden is
also concerned about kamala's ability to
beat Donald Trump which is apparently a
factor on whether he decides to run
again and if Joe wants Kamala off the
ticket it looks like it's too late
our Joe Biden has said he intends to run
and if he does I will be running with
him
intends has said he intends to run for
re-election as president and I intend to
run with him
as Vice President of the United States
Joe Biden is running for reelection and
I will be his ticket mate
full stop full stop
okay so there you have it Hi Sam good to
have you here at the table you know we
didn't do the introductions yeah all
right all right all right let's do it
welcome to the five I'm Judge Jeanine
Pirro and with us is Greg Gutfeld yes
Sandra Smith
Jesse Waters
Richard Richard Ty Richard Tyler
Richard Tyler
and this is the fight thanks guys that
really screwed that up Richard Fowler
you know what I owe you one Richard she
does buy me a nice pair of shoes okay
all right so here we go that's what
happens when they change the
teleprompter all right so here we are
Richard Fowler I'm gonna go to you first
Richard Fowler and I'm going to say that
for the rest of the show so I never say
Richard Tyler again all right you know
we've heard reports that Kamal is
complaining that she doesn't get enough
of the real serious stuff to do and yet
it sounds like the president is saying
she doesn't take some of the pressure or
some of the weighty stuff off his plate
enough to help him out what's the truth
look I always hate these stories with
Anonymous sources I hated it during the
Trump Administration I hate it now when
you have like close sources to the
president and Anonymous who who only
decided to speak on the story because
they were Anonymous so we don't know who
he or she was so they could say whatever
the hell they want uh and so I have a
problem with that um and look I I say
this we are about a year and a couple of
months away from this election and a lot
can happen in that time frame this time
in 2021 there was a conversation about a
red wave that didn't happen I think
what's working in the vice president's
favor is time uh and I think we're gonna
have to wait to see what happens and I
think while this is what we're talking
about the president and the vice
president it's also worth pointing out
that we do not know who the Republican
nominee is going to be and there's going
to be a bitter fight on the Republican
side so before we could figure out who's
who's facing who who's going to be on
the Democratic ticket we also have to
figure out who's going to be on the
Republican side so there's a lot of
things that has to happen so I'm not
making any predictions yet and I think
the American people need to wait to see
because they haven't even had a vote on
anything yet
rhs in Tuesday's last Monmouth poll
Biden was at 41 approval and we heard
that Biden was going to announce after
Christmas then he was going to announce
after the midterms uh and I mean after
the midterms after Christmas and state
of the union and it's still not official
why do you think he's dragging on that
decision
he doesn't have to rush it and he may be
waiting to see what's going on with
these investigations he doesn't look
that healthy if you just saw him out
there with Trudeau he seemed exhausted
and this wasn't a trip to Asia or Europe
This was just over the Border North
so I guess Jill and Joe have decided but
they have not formally announced you
know a lot goes into these things it's
like a lot of Pomp and Circumstance he
was just over in Europe going you know
Behind Enemy Lines to Ukraine it takes a
lot for a guy who's 80 years old to get
it going and he's traditionally had a
hard time making decisions I expect him
to announce uh he will announce and he
will announce now with Kamala Harris as
his running mate because if you remember
in the beginning of the year there was a
lot of momentum to peel that woman off
the ticket and it wasn't just anonymous
source here there were people on the
record suggesting that they peel this
woman off the ticket it looks like
they've now resigned to themselves to
the fact that she is staying on this
ticket and you are stuck with Kamala
Harris and Joe Biden is stuck with
Kamala Harris and this Reuters piece
tells me that Joe's saying I'm tired I
need a little help and she's not helping
maybe he helped Obama more than she
helped him but it's not just on the
policy issues she's not even schmoozing
one of these sources says she doesn't
even go out to dinner and have drinks in
Washington and make friends like the
establishment isn't even thrilled with
her so the donors don't like her The
Establishment doesn't like her she's
less popular than Joe Brown I think
she's at 36 percent so
um this is a a marriage of convenience
at this point they're stuck with each
other and it's going to hang over that
their heads for a long time because an
80 year old
everyone's going to look past them you
know Sandra what Jesse is saying is is
very true I mean shouldn't Democrats be
alarmed at the fact that you know you've
got the president and the vice president
she isn't doing uh you know some of the
more visible issues and going out there
on issues and proposing Solutions and we
know that they don't really get along
and you know why aren't more Democrats
stepping up to the plate when they
realize Joe's numbers are bad a few
months I think it was a month ago we
heard that there were a number of
Congress people who anonymously didn't
want Joe to run I mean what's taking the
Democrats so long to say you know what
these two are not what we need in the
party she sits down in Friendly
interview situations she's on the global
stage she has laughed at Major crises at
this Administration has on its plate
right now she's struggled to Define uh
the role of the vice presidency in a
very recent friendly interview as well
if you were to strip politics out of it
though and just look at this as the
first female in the White House and as a
woman watching no matter what her
decisions are what her politics are you
sort of hope that you would see a strong
leader in the White House first female
leader in the white house so a lot of
people are looking at the fact that I I
just ran this by my team I said what day
was it that she was named the Border
Czar by Joe Biden guess what we looked
it up a minute ago March 24th 2021 I
mean think about that two years she's
been the borders are and we have seen a
surge at our Southern border this
country has never seen when was the last
time you saw her talk about it or visit
the Border or address this as a growing
very serious situation look I'll say
this one last thing because I know Greg
wants to get in here but you've got
single moms all over this country who
are taking on second jobs to pay for
their kids education pay for their kids
sports to pay the grocery bills they're
not happy that Wall Street Journal poll
that came out today people are not happy
in this country and they're worried
about the future of their children in
this country and they look at the
leadership in the white house they don't
see these two out there really tackling
the major issues and that is going to be
a problem that's going to be a problem
for these guys it's going to be a
problem for the party come the
presidential election you know Greg in
terms of foreign policy uh Biden only as
an approval rating of 39 percent now we
just heard him talking about China and
and Russia and now we've got him up in
Canada uh isn't that something that is
very very worrisome to most Americans
well it is kind of scary uh you know
while the Chinese president's meeting
with Putin you know our president is you
know up in the attic with Justin you
know it's like while Darth Vader and the
in the shark from Jaws are planning to
kill us he's seeking help from Bambi I
mean it's just like those two versus the
other two it's a little frightening it's
pretty funny Joe saying that Kamala
isn't someone who takes anything off his
plate would you I mean all he eats is
cream of wheat and Kaopectate nothing
good there she's supposed to be less
popular than him by the way that that's
the reason why he's still on office
right but it's interesting the criticism
about her has suddenly shifted uh now
they're saying she doesn't rise to the
the occasion she doesn't uh
she had this confidence but it hasn't
been shown right so what that does it
takes to stink off Joe right because Joe
assumed she was capable so it's on her
for not stepping up that's different
than saying I screwed the pooch by you
know hiring this cackling deadbeat but
her speech patterns are going to be
studied by Scholars for centuries
because she's able to use words as
punctuation and pauses but never uses
words as words this is amazing she's
able to pad the thinnest gruel with
linguistic helper it's amazing if she
had a richer vocabulary she might get
away with this but she doesn't so she
has to keep using the same words over
and over again like she's patting a term
paper I find it highly entertaining I'm
only mad that we couldn't listen to more
of that presser
[Laughter]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else